[Musique]
mon général comme nous l'avons dit hier
nous allons parler ce soir de la france
par rapport au monde et au milieu du
monde et tout d'abord vous avez fait
allusion hier soir à propos de
l'agriculture au marché commun je crois
qu'il faudrait maintenant aborder cette
question du marché commun en effet on
vous a accusé très nettement de ne pas
croire au marché commun même quelquefois
de vouloir le torpiller en tout cas
d'avoir cassé le marché commun sur la
question de l'agriculture à bruxelles
alors je crois qu'il serait très
important que vous expliquez nettement
là dessus très volontiers
j'en ai déjà parlé bien souvent enfin
nous allons revenir sur les choses et
mettre les points sur les i rien n'est
plus logique si tenté que la logique
conduisent monde
rien n'est plus logique aujourd'hui que
de constituer un marché commun européen
il y à des pays qui sont voisins entre
eux la france l'allemagne l'italie la
hollande la belgique le luxembourg un
jour probablement lors de terre un jour
o'shea l'espagne peut être d'autres
voilà sept géographique qui est devenu
aussi un fait économique parce qu'ils
sont très rapprochés parce que ils sont
en contact immédiat direct les uns avec
les autres et puis parce qu'ils sont du
même ordre économique
les uns et les autres ils sont au même
étiage dans leur ensemble
enfin parce que aujourd'hui la
concurrence est nécessaire c'est
l'aiguillon qui est indispensable au
progrès et notamment aux progrès
économique qui serait absurde pour un
pays de s'enfermer comme on le faisait
autrefois comme nous le faisions
autrefois dans des douanes et les
barrières et que par conséquent pour se
mettre à la page
jour après jour année après année il
faut encore une fois la concurrence bref
il vaut un marché étendu
c'est pourquoi je suis tout à fait
convaincu que je crois mais c'est comme
tout le monde qu'il est bon qu'il est
utile et même qu'il est nécessaire
d'aboutir à créer un marché commun entre
les 6 cependant moi qui ai fait le
traité de rome qui comme vous le savez a
institué en principe ce marché commun
une preuve que si j'avais été aux
affaires quand on a fait le traité de
rome
on l'aurait fait d'une manière assez
différente mais enfin je les prix comme
il était et avec mon gouvernement nous
avons tâché d'en tirer le meilleur parti
possible
qu'est ce que ça voulait ça voulait dire
au point de vue industriel que
progressivement et à mesure que notre
industrie à nous se mettent à la hauteur
des industries concurrentes en
particulier l'industrie allemand est
bien pouvait ouvrir on devait ouvrir les
barrières douanières et communiquer
largement entre soi
il fallait bien entendu des règles à
toutes sortes des gars et je conviens
que le traité de rome prévoit ces règles
pour l'industrie d'une manière
raisonnable
et puis à l'agriculture un pays comme le
nôtre ne peut pas se lancer dans la
concurrence économique du moment qu'elle
ne serait qu'un industriel parce que si
nous restions avec sur les bras
le poids de notre agriculture qui est
très lourd j'ai parlé hier de la
transformation agricole et luxe que
l'état doit faire pour cette
transformation
si nous restions seul par une et six par
exemple avec la charge exclusive de
notre agriculture
nous serions handicapés dans la
concurrence industrielle et pour nous le
marché commun deviendrait qu'une duperie
mais il faut bien convenir que le traité
de rome ne parler que très vaguement de
ceux qui étaient agricole il parlait
très largement une manière très
explicite de ce qui était industriels
mais je le répète très vaguement de
skate it agricole soit parce que l'école
dirigeante d'alors se souciait dans les
relations internationales et les
conventions internationales de faire
beaucoup plaisir aux autres et les
autres c'était des puissances
industrielles avant tout l'industrie
allemand soit parce que le problème de
l'encré de l'agriculture française dans
le marché commun était un problème
énorme que on reculait devant cette
nécessité et ben depuis que moi même et
mon gouvernement nous avons pris en main
l'application du traité de rome la mise
en oeuvre du traité de rome nous nous
sommes acharnés à faire entrer
l'agriculture française dans le marché
commun et ce n'est pas commode pourquoi
parce que je vous le répète nous sommes
à cet égard un pays très particulier
nous avons une agriculture très
considérable à tous les égards ce qui
n'est pas le cas des autres
un pays comme l'allemagne comment se
nourrit ti il se nourrit ap
pour la moitié de ce qui produit et le
reste il importe
et puis nous ce n'est pas le cas nos
agriculteurs sont doublés plus que nous
en mangeons
ils font de la viande et il devrait en
faire plus que nous pouvons à manger et
le peuvent ils font du lait plus que
l'en but vont ils font du vin plus que
nous à sorbon ils font du fromage plus
que nous n'arrivons à le manger sur nos
tables que ça doit être exportée
exporter ou exportés dans le marché
commun pensez bien que ce n'est pas sans
mal qu'on pouvait réaliser cela c'est à
quoi je le répète nous sommes appliqués
à ce point que le 1er janvier 1963 et
les jours qui suivirent est venu
l'échéance oblin l'agriculture française
entre dans le marché commun et les
autres acceptent ou bien est-ce que nous
n'allons pas arrêter le marché commun et
nous avons mis c'est le cas de le dire
ce marché à la main de nos partenaires
ils ont consenti ce jour là ces jours là
à faire entrer l'agriculture française
dans le marché commun mais il suffisait
pas de le dire sol elle sert et c'était
pas commode la preuve c'est qu'à la
dernière échéance c'est-à-dire le 30
juin dernier où il fallait effectivement
abouti avec le règlement financier
on n'a pas pu aboutir nous avons trouvé
encore toutes sortes de réticence devant
nous et pas moyen d'aller plus loin
alors que faire eh bien il faut en
prendre la question et comme vous le
savez comme nous l'avons dit nous y
sommes pour nous pour notre part nous
français tout disposés et même réseau à
condition bien entendu que ce soit pour
aboutir et qu'on ne vienne pas à d'orner
si je peux dire
entrée de l'agriculture française dans
le marché commun qui complétera
l'ensemble économique et 6 on aille pas
a donné cela deux conditions politiques
dont nous aurons peut-être a parlé tout
à l'heure et qui au point de vue de la
france
évidemment ne sont pas acceptables voilà
où en sont les choses voilà la route qui
est ouverte et voilà les espoirs que
nous avons en général je crois que le
marché commun ça nous amène presque
automatiquement à l'europe
et là encore si je disais tout à l'heure
on vous a accusé d'être contre marché
commun de ne pas y croire de ne pas le
vouloir on vous accuse aussi très
fréquemment de ne pas être européens et
de ne pas croire à l'europe
et pourtant vous avez parlé un jour ou
tout au moins on a essayé de définir
votre conception de l'europe en disant
l'europe des patries
vous avez souvent parlé de l'europe de
l'atlantique à l'oural seulement
l'europe des patries j'ai l'impression
que ceux qui se croient qu'ils se disent
européen trouve que ce n'est pas assez
et l'europe de l'atlantique à l'oural
ils trouvent que c'est trop
alors je vous pose très nettement la
question mon général est ce que vous
êtes européens ou non newmont je suis
français je suis européen étant donné
que nous sommes en europe et que je
dirais même que la france a toujours été
une partie essentielle
sinon capitale de l'europe par
conséquent bien sûr que sur ben alors on
me demandait si je suis pour une
organisation de l'europe
et si je vous entends bien vous voulez
parler d'une organisation de l'europe
occidentale
à cet égard je ne sais pas si vous
arrive de relire des déclarations que
j'ai pu faire depuis des années les
années si cela vous arrive vous
apercevrez que j'ai parlé de l'europe et
en particulier de la conjonction de la
gaude groupement de l'europe occidentale
avant que personne n'en pas et même en
pleine guerre parce que je crois que
c'est un effet indispensable je crois
qu'il y a dès lors que nous nous battons
plus entre européens occidentaux et l'or
qui a plus de rivalité immédiate
y a pas de guerre ni mais denis même de
guerre imaginables entre la france et
l'allemagne entre la france et l'italie
même bien entendu un jour entre la
france l'allemagne l'italie et
d'angleterre
eh bien il est absolument normal que
s'établisse entre ces pays occidentaux
une solidarité c'est cela l'europe et je
crois que cette solidarité doit être
organisé il s'agit de savoir comment et
sous quelle forme alors il faut prendre
les choses comme elles sont 47 politique
autrement que sur des réalités bien
entendu on peut sauter sur sa chaise
comme un cabri en disant l'europe
l'europe l'europe mais ça n'aboutit à
rien et ça ne signifie à rien je répète
il faut prendre les choses comme elles
sont comment sont-elles vous avez un
pays français pour pouvoir discuter
berlin vous avez un pays allemand pour
discuter en un vous avez un pays qu à
rien
j'avais appris belge de l'impie
hollandais vous avez un pays
luxembourgeois et vous avez un peu plus
loin un pays en anglais et vous avez un
pays espagnol et cetera ce sont des pays
ils ont leur histoire ils ont leur
langue ils ont leur manière de vivre et
ils sont des français des allemands des
italiens les anglais des hollandais des
espagnols des luxembourgeois ce sont ces
pays là qu'il faut mettre ensemble et ce
sont ces pays là qu'il faut habituer
progressivement à vivre ensemble et à
agir ensemble
à cet égard je suis le premier à
reconnaître et à penser que le marché
commun était centièmes car si on arrive
à l'organiser et par conséquent à
établir une réelle solidarité économique
entre ces pays européens on aura fait
beaucoup pour leur rapprochement
fondamentale et pour leur vie commune
alors il ya le domaine politique que
peuvent-ils faire en commun
politiquement il y a deux choses à
considérer
quand on parle de politique de tout
temps et notamment par le temps qui
courent il ya à considérer la différence
dans le cas où on serait obligé de ce
destin et pia considérer l'action c'est
à dire ce que l'on fait au dehors
au point de vue de la défense sur cette
europe occidentale devait être attaqué
et par qui pourraient l'être jusqu'à
présent ou plutôt jusqu'à ces derniers
temps on pourrait imaginer qu'elle
risquait de lettres partir de l'est et
je n'ai pas encore absolument impossible
dans ce cas là il y à une solidarité de
défense entre les six et cette
solidarité
je le crois peut et doit être organisé
et puis à l'action c'est à dire ce que
cet ensemble devrait faire dans le monde
alors à cet égard là c'est beaucoup plus
difficile car il faut bien convenir que
les uns et les autres ne font pas tous
la même chose et ne voient pas tous les
choses de la même façon les allemands
que voulez vous il se voit comme ils
sont c'est à dire coupé en deux et même
trois si l'on tient compte du statut de
berlin et genre un trou avec une
puissance économique naissante et qui
est déjà considérable
forcément ils ont des ambitions est il
nécessaire que les ambitions de
l'allemagne soit automatiquement les
nôtres les anglais ont à faire un peu
partout et on le voit bien il en disant
barras actuellement en afrique avec
l'ardesi ils en ont dans les pays arabes
avec aden ils en ont en extrême orient
avec la malaisie et ainsi de suite
est-ce que
ses ennuis ces inconvénients doivent
être nécessairement les nôtres en même
temps oui ou ce que je veux dire il est
pas si facile que ça d'ajuster les
politiques
alors j'ai fait peut-être vous en
souvenez vous c'était en 1961 la
première de toutes les propositions qui
était faite aux européens pour commencer
une coopération politique
je leur ai proposé de réunir
périodiquement en sang les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement et puis les
différentes sortes des ministres
notamment emile affaires étrangères pour
confronter la situation de chacun et vue
de chacun et les accords d osisko n'ayez
pas trop prononcé la formule est ce
qu'on avait appellé l'europe des patries
je n'ai jamais parlé d'europe des pâtres
c'est comme la tendance sus il chacun à
sa patrie nous avons la nôtre
les allemands la leur les anglais ont la
leur et c'est ainsi
j'ai parlé de la coopération des états
alors ça oui j'en ai parlé et je crois
que c'est indispensable et nous avons
tâché de l'organiser à cette époque mais
ça n'a pas réussi et depuis on n'a plus
rien fait excepté qui avons fait quelque
chose avec l'allemagne car nous avons
solennellement j'étais d'incroyables
après tout ce qui nous était arrivé nous
avons solennellement fait avec
l'allemagne un traité de réconciliation
et de coopération
ça n'a pas non plus jusqu'à présent
donné grand chose parce que parce que
les politiques sont les politiques des
états et qu'on ne peut pas empêcher ça
alors vous avez des crimes
km tous ensemble yaka trompent tous
ensemble on sait que les allemands les
italiens les anglais et cetera oui
j'avais c'est commode et quelquefois
c'est assez séduisant on va ce régime
est rendra sur des mythes mais ce ne
sont que les chimères est dit
ils y allaient réalité et la réalité se
traite pas comme ça
les réalités se traite à partir d'elle
même et c'est ce que nous nous efforçons
de faire et c'est ce que nous nous
proposons de continuer à faire si nous
arrivons à surmonter l'épreuve du marché
commun j'espère bien que nous le ferons
il faudra reprendre ce que la france a
proposé en 62 et qui n'avait pas réussi
à 61 et qui n'avait pas réussi du
premier coup
c'est à dire l'organisation d'une
coopération politique naissante entre
les états de l'europe occidentale et à
ce moment là il est fort probable
un peu plus tôt un peu plus tard
l'angleterre vient d'emploi et ce sera
tout naturel bien entendu se replacera
pas que maudit supranationale elle sur
un comme elle est elle commencera par
est une coopération
peut-être qu'après à force de vivre
ensemble elle deviendra une
confédération
eh bien je n'envisage pas volontiers je
n'ai pas de l'impossible mon général je
voudrais maintenant vous poser un
certain nombre d'autres questions je me
permets de vous de vous rappeler parce
que tout en vous écoutant j'ai l'oeil
sur le chronomètre excusez moi que nous
avons encore à peu près 12 minutes
je voudrais vous poser la question
suivante on dit aussi très fréquemment
que vous êtes anti américain vous avez
une fois parler d'hégémonie américaine
les américains en mal pris cela ils ont
considéré que c'était péjoratif et même
beaucoup de français considèrent que
c'est péjoratif
alors est ce que vous pourriez également
là dessus vous expliquer sur votre anti
américanisme savait depuis
j'ai eu à faire une action nationale
c'est à dire depuis 1940 qui était en
même temps et l'action internationale je
ne suis toujours entendu traiter d'anti
quelque chose je me rappelle avec ce
pauvre cherche il me disait vous un anti
britannique
c'était assez drôle puisque j'étais
actuellement avec ceux qui m'entouraient
nous étions les seuls français qui
soyons restés à combattre aux côtés de
l'angleterre
les américains après on dit vous êtes
anti américain et alors ils sont
présentés en afrique du nord sans
vouloir que je vienne avec eux à cause
du fait qu'il me considérait comme anti
américain
et là les français qui étaient encore
sous l'obédience de vichy leur ont tiré
dessus partout liban en réalité qui a
été l'allié des américains de bout en
bout
sinon la france de 2 go ils n'avaient
pas eu d'autre et le cas échéant si le
malheur devait arriver ici la liberté du
monde était en cause qui serait
automatiquement les meilleurs alliés
la nature sinon la france et les états
unis comme ils l'ont été
souvent en pareil cas d'ailleurs vous
avez moi je dis pas que les américains
sont anti français et pourtant alors si
c'est parce que nous les avions ne sont
pas toujours accompagné qui serait anti
français eh bien ils nous ont pas
toujours accompagné en 1914 que
voulez-vous nous étions en guerre contre
guillaume ii et les américains n'étaient
pas là ils sont arrivés en 1917
ils ont fort bien fait pour eux et pour
tout le monde en 1940 il n'était pas là
et nous avons été submergés par hitler
et ce n'est qu'en 41
parce que les japonais ont coulé une
partie de la flotte américaine a peur
pour que les états unis sont entrés dans
la guerre
loin de moi l'idée de me connaître iman
services qu'ils ont rendus à eux au
monde et à nous mêmes en entrant dans la
guerre en 1917 et en entrant dans la
guerre en 1941
je le sais bien mais enfin je ne dis pas
qu'ils sont anti français parce qu'ils
ne sont pas accompagnés toujours je suis
pas anti américain parce qu'actuellement
je n'accompagne pas les américains
pauvres et en particulier par exemple
dans la politique qu'il mène en asie il
est tout à fait vrai que je ne les en
approuve pas alors de là à dire je suis
américain anti américain je ne peux pas
les laisser dans leur péché mais vous
voyez le fond des choses
en général je voudrais que vous
répondiez à deux autres questions
maintenant qui touche certaines dépenses
engagées par votre politique et que
beaucoup jugent exagérée à savoir les
dépenses pour la force de frappe et les
dépenses pour l'aide aux pays du
tiers-monde
nous avions une armée je suis arrivé
c'est l'armée lg rim pour vers le mot sa
nouveauté 30 % de notre budget
actuellement nous avons une qui est en
train de se rénover complètement abattu
huit elle nous coûte 21 % de notre
budget est entre-temps meuron 10002
parce que de moitié la durée du service
militaire
si nous n'avions pas cette force
atomique qui l'instrument terrible dont
la capacité d'une dissuasion
même quand elle n'est pas en chiffres
équivalente à celle des colas est tout
de même énorme du dissuasion et de
sauvegarde si nous l'avions pas ça
qu'est ce que nous aurions ou bien nous
aurions pas d'armé du tout c'est une
conception
alors on parle plus de la france dans la
coopération du monde pour sa défense et
par conséquent pour sa politique ou bien
alors nous aurions une armée comme on
dit conventionnel alors ce serait l'armé
en 1957 et encore faudrait il y aurait
un armement moderne qu'alors elle
n'avait pas ça nous coûtera encore bien
plus cher que ce que nous sommes en
train de faire maintenant et a suivi
membres et efficace du reste les
allemands qui ne peuvent pas qu'ils
doivent pas se faire d armes atomiques
les allemandes une armée conventionnelle
qui leur coûte relativement plus cher
que nous nous coûte la nôtre voilà le
sait alors on dit les pays sous
développés
c'est bien on parle de dépenses
extraordinaires que nous faisons pour
les pays sous développés ont dit on dit
la france entretient des rois [ __ ] et
elle ne dépense pas l'argent pour elle
la france donne en effet au total
quelque chose comme 2 milliards de
nouveaux francs pour la coopération des
pays sous développés
voilà ce qu'elle fait c'est 2 milliards
c'est pas de l'argent perdu à beaucoup
prennent d'abord c'est ainsi que nous
gardons avec ces pays d'à des liens
extrêmement étroits au point de vue
culturel ça va de soi puisque ils
parlent tous français
au point de vue politique même au point
de vue économique c'est certain
puisqu'ils sont à nos grands débouchés
de nos exportations
et puis enfin au point de vue notre
standing international car il est bon
qu'un pays comme la france et des amis
et des amis qu'ils soient des amis
particuliers pourquoi pas et en effet
c'est ce que nous faisons un pays comme
la france ne veut pas renoncer
un rôle d' aide internationale
elle n'a pas le droit ou alors on ne
serait pas la france et l'est par
conséquent cet argent que nous donnons
pour l'aide aux pays sous-développés de
l'argent perdu aucun point de vue je
considère même que c'est un très bon
placement en général une dernière
question il nous reste encore
cinq minutes 5 minutes et demie vous
parlez très souvent dans vos conférences
de presse dans vos discours dans vos
allocution de l' équilibre du monde que
vous liée à la notion de paix dans le
monde
et puis on vous reproche aussi de
sacrifier volontiers nos alliances
traditionnelles au bénéfice de relations
nouvelles avec les pays de l'est
comment est ce que peut se concilier
cette politique de la france qui est la
vôtre avec le rôle que doit jouer la
france dans les qhs libres du monde et
pour la pétulante nous avons un monde
qui est en train de changer énormément
d'année en année il n'est plus le même
il apparaît les forces nouvelles parle
par exemple de la chine
il y en a d'autres comme la russie
soviétique qui évolue à l'intérieur
d'elle-même et face au dehors il y en a
d'autres comme les états unis qui évolue
aussi et qui d'une puissance
essentiellement isolationniste qu'ils
étaient autrefois devienne une puissance
interventionniste c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
tout s'achète un changement capital et
allemagne qui se transforme et dont nous
ne savons pas absolument pas où iront
ces ambitions naturellement nous
espérons qu'elles vont dans le bon sens
et nous avons des raisons de l'espérer
mais n'ont pas pas dire qu'on en soit
certains par conséquent nous sommes
obligés de prendre le monde comme il est
et d'agir et de vivre dans ce monde
alors qu'est ce que ça signifie ça
signifie que la france n'a à s'interdire
à elle même aucune possibilité
la france est pour la paix il lui faut
la paix la france pour renaître vraiment
on se réfère et pour s'étendre au sens
le plus noble du terme
il lui faut la paix par conséquent la
france cherche la paix cultive la paix
est de l'ape est partout comment en
étant en rapport avec tout le monde
il n'y a aucune espèce de raison pour
que nous excluons d'avoir de bons
pas avec ceux ci ou avec cela nous
sommes les alliés les américains et
leurs amis tant qu il al air de
subsister quelques menaces venant de
l'est sur l'europe occidentale
nous sommes également en termes de plus
en plus étroits avec l'europe de l'est
parce qu'elle existe et basquiat hobbies
ps de raison pour que nous ne prenions
pas tous ses contacts pacifique avec
elle nous avons pris des contacts
également pacifique et étroit déjà assez
avec la chine
nous en avons avec d'autres réalités du
monde comme l'amérique latine comme
l'afrique d'un attendu comme l'un comme
le japon et pourquoi pas ceux que nous
appelons les équilibres qui va avec la
paix c'est un commencement de
coopération internationale et c'est cela
que la france cherche à aider et c'est
pourquoi la france ne l'exclus les
rapports ses rapports avec qui que ce
soit elle cherche être en contact
pratique directe fécond avec tout le
monde il l'est figurez vous je dirais
même qu actuellement dans le monde si
vous ouvrez attention elle est la seule
des américains tout puissants qu'ils
sont ne sont pas en bon terme tout le
monde les anglais non plus pas encore
les allemands je m'en parle pas la
russie soviétique
ce n'est pas certain nous nous sommes ce
pays à ces confort au génie de la france
nous n'en sommes plus à la domination et
à vouloir l'établir
mais nous sommes le peuple fait pour
établir et des la coopération
internationale
c'est ça notre ambition nationale
d'aujourd'hui et faute de celle là nous
n'aurions aucune mais il nous en faut
qu'une et celle là nous l'avons elle est
pour le bien de l'homme elle et pour
l'avenir de l'humanité
il n'y a que la france tu piges jouer ce
jeu là il n'y a que la france
ce qui le joue en général je vous
remercie
puisque vous avez accepté de revenir
demain devant les caméras nous parlerons
si vous voulez bien pour ce troisième et
dernier entretien de la république et
des institutions eh bien nous en
parlerons de la république
[Musique]